major reversal by the cdc it now
recommends
that all americans wear masks indoors
where covet is surging
fueled by the delta variant the cdc's
guidance affects
about 60 percent of u.s counties where
there are substantial or
high transmission rates cbs news has
also learned that all
white house employees regardless of
their vaccination status
are now required to wear masks indoors
and as the new school year approaches
the cdc is also recommending all
students
teachers and staff wear masks our lead
national correspondent david begno is in
baton rouge louisiana
david louisiana just saw the biggest
spike in hospitalizations
since the start of the pandemic they did
anthony in fact here at louisiana's
largest hospital they have 119 cobit
patients this morning they had 62 when
we were here last week it's nearly
doubled
regarding that mass guidance from the
cdc you're going to have some districts
around the country that say
the cdc gave us cover to mandate masks
even though some parents may not like it
but you'll have other districts that say
you know what we're still not going to
mandate it
and those districts that do say that may
have to answer to mothers like this
we're looking for places that will keep
them safe in the south louisiana area
known as acadiana
brittany a bear may be one of the most
outspoken parents you'll find
when it comes to masking i get this
feeling that our children's safety is
coming second to
push back from the community or angry
phone calls
or politics
a bear speaks from authority
she is a doctor and so is her husband
they have both treated covet patients
for the last year
now dr a bear is planning to pull her
kids
out of the public school system because
in lafayette parish they are not
currently requiring masks
when the public school system dropped
their mass mandate in june
just as we were starting to see case
numbers start to rise
it was very telling that they were not
valuing my children's safety
what happens if you don't find a school
in your community well then we'll make a
school in our home
and we are very lucky that we can
financially do that
but it really frustrates and angers me
that there are so many parents
out there who can't do that she may have
found a solution
that works for her family well what
grade you're going in like eighth grade
okay fourth grade this week dr rabear
and her eight-year-old twins
toured a private school that has
throughout the pandemic
followed the cdc's guidance what are you
looking for
they should be masking indoors
nationwide seven states have banned mass
mandates in schools
while six states are still requiring
them the majority of states like
louisiana
have left that decision up to the local
school districts it's really exhausting
to go to work every day and
be worried and scared for my patients
and really want to fight for this
community
i can't control that the community is
not getting on board with these very
easy mitigation strategies whether it's
vaccination
or masking but i can't control if my
kids are
safe so i'm gonna make sure that they
are do you sometimes get a little
self-conscious like
maybe i'm being a little too eager
beaver with all this no
because i have to face the real true
risks of this disease every day
my colleagues see our pediatric
hospitals filling up
and kids getting sicker this time around
these are real risks
and i am not willing to roll the dice
with my kids health
we interviewed dr a bear monday night
not knowing what the cdc was going to
say sure enough they come out tuesday
and say
kids should be masked at school and i
text dr aber and said what do you think
and she said i'm so relieved to finally
have some definitive
messaging that says you need to mask up
in schools by the way that public school
system where her kids
were going and are currently going said
hey
we weren't going to mandate masks but
based on the cdc's new guidance
we're going to take another look gail
david thank you